necessarily stuck in your way i think a
relationship is about compromising and i
think that's when
if you if that's what you want that's
when the power power trip comes involved
and you know and that sort of sense so i
think it is kind of manipulation to a
certain extent for me personally i just
think at 30 what you want at 35 compared
to what you want at 19 are two
completely different things i think i
just think life's about choices and
trade-offs and if you choose to get it
with a guy on that level like you're
kind of on his platform it's not like
power and manipulation if you make that
choice yeah but i think because you can
you can get a guy who like there's so
many sims god
yeah god there's so many you can you
could have a symptom that lets you do
whatever you want and but if you want a
guy that's worth something and that's in
that percentage of guys like you have to
get on his program and those men prefer
women that are impressionable i don't
think that's a bad thing but i think at
19 i think a lot of it
is probably materialistic what you what
you want from a guy in terms of oh my
gosh at 19. oh he has money he drives a
car
you're looking at the material things
whereas when you're a bit older you're
not looking at the material things
you're looking at the kind of you know
what what can we build together and i
think at 19 for to go for a man who's 35
years old it's kind of like what you
said the men's looking for sex and the
woman's looking for for money and that
security and the materialistic things is
that a genuine relationship in my
personal opinion i don't think it is in
the west i would agree with you that's
true like women at that age but like if
you go to more traditional countries
like girls at a younger age
are more likely to i don't know
they just they look for different things
it's really interesting to talk to
people from like muslim cultures where
they just get married a lot younger and
they look for like the family 100 but i
even think even in the western culture
if we go back 30 40 years a lot of our
parents and grandparents they were
probably were married and um had babies
at the age of 19. but then it's funny
because when you speak to them now they
say oh my gosh if i could go back i
would have waited i probably would have
had you know a bit more time to kind of
you know see what i really wanted
because at 19 you are so impressionable
and and you are naive you think you know
what you want but do you really really
my my grandparents like they never said
anything like that to me like they would
have waited like they just had a ton of
kids and they're happy yeah i think they
got to feel i'm not saying everyone's
unhappy the odds of you are probably
happy and it's worked out amazing but
for some people they could still even be
in those happy relations but feel like
they've missed out on an element of
their life where now they're looking at
women
are um in like who are 19 to even 29
these days and you know they're living
their life they're doing that they want
to do and i think you know from not
everyone but from a couple of people
that i've spoke to from the older
generation they do feel like they've
missed out on that element would you say
that would you say we have a better now
um i think there's pros and cons to now
i think um the pros being you know you
don't there's there's not there's still
pressure but there's not as much
pressure i feel like if you was to get
married and have a baby at 35 no one
would blink twice whereas if you was to
do that
20 years ago everyone would be like
what's going on would you would you say
we should learn from them because their
results were better and
if they if they had better outcomes i
think there's elements yeah definitely
yeah
like 50 50 of women that hit 30 are
single and childless and the least happy
demographic of women is women over the
age of 40
that make between 50 and 75 000 per year
so that are like career women
i think yeah i think you have a point
there about um
elements of learning from older
generations for sure i think going back
to the whole like andrew tate clip and
what we were saying there i'd be really
interested to hear from like the guys in
the room like
let's imagine you guys have met the love
of your life right you get married
you've been with her for years
you have a son
son is like minnie you're super proud of
him you have a daughter she's apple of
your eye she's like daddy's girl wrapped
around your finger right
you've raised them all in the right way
in terms of values blah blah blah she
comes home she's 19 and she says dad
i've met someone who is 35 39 um i
really want to be with him because he
says that i'm young and i'm
impressionable and he wants to have an
imprint on me
how would you feel
oh you're throwing it like that you must
have it in front of you i mean
can i ask you a question can they ask
is he trying to marry her or date her
we don't know okay
it's just started then yeah we don't
know no i mean
the time they've met it's just the
beginning again we don't know oh we
don't know they could have been going in
interpret as you wish i mean as a man
even like for who my sister would be
with generally i get a gist you talk you
communicate to the person because i was
going to intervene and come back to what
you were saying and say if i was an
older man going for
personally i wouldn't go that long i've
got a rule like i don't go five years
below i don't know if i'm right or wrong
for that but
if i had the intentions of showing them
how good life could be
let's forget the sex element sex is
always gonna come if you're with the
opposite sex you're most likely going to
do it but what if i was showing her from
1819 you can start thinking about
finances you don't have to follow your
friends who are going to run around and
get
sorry quote unquote ran through but you
could start thinking about things ahead
of time
why does it always have to be in a
negative connotation
i could be giving her all of these life
skills yeah early and even if we split
up she's got that for life
yeah 100 in that sense but then it's
still like are you getting what you want
out of that of course i mean i'll get
that
i mean he would get that regardless the
top g the top 5 10 of men if you're a
high value man you're going to get that
because the choices go from any range
you want okay so you're happy for your
daughter at this stage what do you think
no i mean i agree with that i think as a
father i would hopefully be able to
assess like intention and i could be
wrong but if he's like a genuinely nice
guy and a good person and all that stuff
then i wouldn't see anything
particularly wrong with it okay though i
always have always had a problem with
age gaps um i've fallen into my own
situations where and i was way older
sort of thing
it's always kind of bothered me but
i think for the sake of your question if
i was just a father and like my 19 year
old daughter was like i'm dating this 35
year old guy and he comes into the house
and he's just a genuinely good person
and everything you described i have no
problem with it but you know even with
the comment that she mentioned he's
talking like entertaining well if
as a man you see we again society is
teaching us what's right what's wrong
especially in the last 50 years when
women didn't have as much power so
nowadays we're all being careful i just
told you an example where i asked the
lady i was talking to
could you not um wear that and i'm
telling you it was so difficult because
if i go above and beyond i'm in trouble
or i could be offending her it's so
marginal now so
again
how much power do we have telling our
daughter who and who not to date
do you get what i mean so it's not like
it's that easy what you presented
because we have to look it as a whole
our wife may intervene and be like don't
tell a talker what to do because now
you're embracing sexism so that's where
our society is at it's so it's not that
easy for us to answer these things okay
so may or may not be dating andrew take
cool wait if i mean i would um as a man
i'll still be like god damn why him of
all people okay if billy down the road
is good andrew
but not andrew can i just check
something you said you fell into a
relationship or into a situation with
with someone younger
how do you
was that just a like a miscommunication
of words how do you fall into a
situation with someone younger i'm
talking well a bit of both so yes and no
the lawyer to me um sometimes you find
yourself in a situation where you start
to connect with someone and despite your
better intentions
you have fallen for someone so but if
you've connected with them and you fall
in with someone and if they're not under
the legal age then
then there's no problem